[Music]
welcome my rental law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin
the widow of basketball star kobe bryant
is accusing her mother
of extorting an illegal battle over
family money
vanessa bryant's mother is suing her for
financial support
claiming she worked unpaid as a personal
assistant and nanny for the family
sophia lane claims in the lawsuit that
kobe promised to take care of her for
the rest of her life
kobe and 13 year old gianna died in a
helicopter crash
in january vanessa took to social media
to refute the allegations
saying she watched our girls from time
to time just like most grandparents do
she now wants to back charge me 96
dollars per hour
for supposedly working 12 hours a day
for 18 years
she said her mother is demanding 5
million dollars a house
and a mercedes suv vanessa went on to
call the lawsuit frivolous
disgraceful and unimaginably hurtful
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney linda kenny baden along with
terry austin
linda i'm just asking for another host
maybe their mother is watching because
he's the anchor of this show now
but is this real that mothers can do
this to their children and
charge them for babysitting their
grandchildren
well you know there is an old uh author
named charles dickens wrote a book about
bleak house
by fighting families with wills and it
took like
decades and decades and decades to
delete the money
this is kind of like the modern day
version isn't it 95.96
an hour uh usually when you see this
brian it's because
somebody wants to then be paid their
services that they were giving an estate
for free
and then the estate doesn't fight it
because they want to be able to deduct
it
from the estate value and give it to
someone else
at a different value but this seems to
be a grandmother and i use that term
loosely only genetically it appears who
really wants to engage in a modern day
bleak house
a modern day fight and quite frankly
sophia elaine if this is really
what you do as a parent and a
grandparent really
i mean really no one should even give
you the time of day
now terry with no formal agreement to
pay for this babysitting
do you think this case is dead on
arrival well i hope it's dead on arrival
i agree
with linda i cannot believe sophia lane
is
suing her own daughter for babysitting i
mean
we know that vanessa bryan is a
full-time mom
always has been and of course the
grandmother is going to come and visit
the children
but for her to sue saying that she's
owed money and that
kobe promised to take care of her for
life i think that
is extremely distressful and i agree
with
you know vanessa here all right thank
you very much both i'll make sure to
carry that on to that
anchor i was telling about and his mom
uh an update in the chad and lori
daybell
case terry austin has the latest brian
the judge ruled a hearing over
allegations of prosecutorial misconduct
will be closed to the public
laurie vallo is charged alongside her
husband
chad dabell after bodies of her two
children
were discovered on chad's property
seven-year-old joshua j.j
valo and sixteen-year-old tyler ryan
were found dead
ten months after they were reported
missing
their defense attorneys say prosecutor
rob wood
intimidated a witness over the phone
long crimes executive trial producer
kathy russon explains
prosecutor rob wood allegedly were
saying things to summer lori's sister
like your sister is going to be charged
as an accessory to murder
this could be a death penalty case he
allegedly in that recording talks about
how
chad dabell is the mastermind behind all
of this but he has
his best evidence against her sister
lori and i will say that
part of what we know that is in that
recording is apparently
rob wood is like demeaning mark means
saying that he's in over his head so
this is i'm all paraphrasing
rob wood also says the part of the
recording that he heard was not the full
conversation that was had and he
believes it's been altered or edited in
some
fashion terry we're also learning that
lori and chad have waived their right to
a speedy trial
can you kind of explain what that is and
how that applies here
well usually a defendant is going to
waive the right to a speedy trial and
they have that right under the sixth
amendment of the constitution
but they usually waive it if you know in
fact the defense
needs more time but here they are in
jail and so it's a little odd that
they're waving their right but you know
not much can happen at this point in
time
anyway because of covet 19. yeah linda
that
that key factor the fact that they're
incarcerated is oftentimes reason why i
don't wave
a person's right to a speedy trial do
you think this is a wise move by the
defense considering
copen 19 and that their clients are
incarcerated
absolutely quite frankly with all due
respect brian i always say when people
and defense attorneys want to push
speedy trial i say
what are you talking about if you have a
complicated case if you have a forensic
case if you have a case where witnesses
could flip you the case we are charging
the prosecutor
with tampering with witnesses you want
to have a long time because anything can
happen that will help you later on in
the trial
so i agree with the defense here i think
it was a wise move a smart move
even if the defendants are incarcerated
hey maybe they're playing chess instead
of checkers
terry would you agree as well maybe this
is the case you might want to stretch
out just a little
to make it a little better for your case
down the road what do you think
i think i always agree with linda
because she knows what she's talking
about stretch it out get more
information and defend your client
yeah of course because for all you know
these witnesses may fall apart
memories fade is that kind of the tactic
here linda because
there's nothing really going to happen
anytime soon based on the current
climate of the country
that's right and you may end up losing
that prosecutor quite frankly any
prosecutor who's demeaning a defense
attorney
for the defendant's side may be guilty
of misconduct i mean that's an
allegation that's going to be made and
even if the judge doesn't remove the
prosecutor then
he may act a little bit more judiciously
if indeed those allegations were true so
anything can happen here brian yeah so
time can be on their side we'll see if
it is for
this case as we move on to the next
issue that we're talking about
still ahead on law and crime daily the
family of a man killed after an off-duty
police officer
put him in a chokehold wants answers but
first porch pirates this holiday season
learn what you can do to protect
yourself after the break
[Music]
with the holidays right around the
corner and people using delivery more
and more
thefts are on the rise lawn crime
daily's angenette levy has some tips
on how to deal with these porch pirates
yeah brian you know ordering by nail
right now is even bigger because of the
pandemic which is
making porches right targets for thieves
every year like clockwork porch pirates
hit homes across the country
social media is full of photos like this
one from martin county
where a resident helped idea suspect
it's on the rise now where people who
never thought about doing something like
this now do it because of the
opportunity
so people are out there cruising
neighborhoods cruising through
trying to find packages for the sole
purpose of just
you know sweetening the pot for
themselves crime analyst lisa lockwood
says
mask wearing because of covid19 has
given porch pirates a sense of security
and a disguise that doesn't seem
suspicious
in richmond virginia this brazen thief
wore a mask
and a delivery vest to snatch a package
in one ohio neighborhood
package thefts became so common around
the holidays
that one police department started
allowing residents to have packages
delivered to the police station
this year more than 100 packages have
been accepted
so they come in and we actually have our
own labeling system
so we stack we actually put our own
label back on it
and then then it gets numbered and it
goes back into
a storage area and then we actually
notify the resident that they're here
in carlsbad california a police officer
gave balloons to a child whose birthday
gift was stolen
on his birthday lisa lockwood offers
advice to keep from becoming a porch
pirate's next target
it's something of high value a high
value item
request that you get a signature for
that item
now lockwood says there are other things
you can do like
asking a neighbor to pick up something
for you once you get the notification
that a package has been delivered she
also says it's a really good idea to
have packages delivered to those
amazon lockers and packages on porches
aren't the only thing being targeted
right now brian get this
this is crazy in the cleveland area in
the last few weeks
five amazon delivery trucks have
actually been stolen
while they were being delivered those
packages were being delivered to
people's homes so
they have to watch out for that along
with the packages on the porches
we'll send it back to you thanks for
that and jeanette
back with me are terry austin and linda
kenny boden
terry first of all great name porch
pirates
but we're hearing different ways to
protect ourselves and especially now
during cover 19 with more packers being
delivered
for me isn't this a federal crime there
could be some serious
repercussions for these people stealing
off your property right
well you know one of the things that the
states are doing
without the federal protection in place
is
they are increasing the penalties for
the crime so
you have in texas governor greg abbott
just made this
into a felony instead of a misdemeanor
so you could literally get
10 years in president in prison and a 10
fine so even if we don't have some sort
of federal protection
we do have states looking into this and
trying to make it
a more serious crime yeah now linda i
know you and i have uh some very
let's call them majestic and beautiful
four-legged senses of security
yours of poodle and mine and doberman to
help with this but can you think of any
other ideas as to how to protect your
home from these porch pirates well a
couple things one of the things you saw
there on the internet and it's ironic
because amazon now owns it with the ring
doorbell right
ring doorbell is there that's how you
collect the fact that somebody has taken
your items
uh amazon as i see that that truck right
there
that does that looks like it's an
enterprise rental truck what amazon has
done is hired people
that are not an amazon trucks or an
enterprise different trucks their own
enterprise rental whatever and it looks
like this person is taking advantage of
it
so i think really you have to go to the
lockers you have to have it delivered to
somebody else that is going to be home
that can accept it for you or ask your
place of work if the package can be
delivered there brian
yeah especially with so many people
working from home they've got work
supplies coming in the holidays are
coming up
we hope that they can find creative ways
to staying safe and also making sure
their packages get there on time when
they're supposed to
i know we saw in one clip there of the
officers
showing up with balloons because a young
boy had his packages stolen
that's horrible but also good on that
officer for bringing a little bit of joy
to his community coming up on law and
crime daily the tiger king is suing the
u.s government
why he says president trump wasn't given
a chance to pardon him
plus the 911 call you need to listen to
why the family of a man heard gasping
for air is calling for justice
[Music]
attorneys for the family of a man who
died after an off-duty police officer
used a choke hold
to have him released a 9-1-1 call from
the incident
milwaukee police officer michael marioli
is facing charges of first-degree
reckless homicide
according to court records marioli says
he was attacked at a party at his home
in april by joel acevedo an attorney for
acevedo's families says that's not true
and claims marioli held acevedo in a
chokehold for 11 minutes
acevedo can be heard in the background
of a call
saying quote let me go
home hello
[Music]
police officer's house it's very
fantastic
okay what's this man's name
teddy mr well
the officer has since resigned from the
department but the victim's family is
calling for a full
prosecution my
son's life mattered
and they refused to let him go home
their anger their aggression
they did not even marioli's he did not
even have no remorse after the fact
that he held my son for over 11 minutes
on a chokehold
he has no remorse even to today
this is our frustration that we know
what went on in there it's obvious
and it's even more obvious that michael
manioli
along with his so-called attorney is
trying to sue the city
to keep the videotape to come out
because the videotape is going to show
more evidence damaging evidence against
him and these other two individuals
the family received the 9-1-1 call after
filing a lawsuit against the police
department
their attorney says the body cam video
from responding officers should also be
made public
um myself along with members of the
acevedo family have seen
um a great deal of the body count
footage especially the parts
that led up to officer mattioli being
instructed by a fellow officer to get up
i think that the moments leading up you
can see
clearly marioli on top of straddling
acevedo
using his body weight against marioli
choking him you can also see another
individual
holding joelle's legs down while officer
marioli was allowed to choke him
um i think that information and i think
that evidence is very critical
the defendant is due back in court in
march
when we come back new arrests in the
jeffrey epstein case
more associates of the millionaire
pedophile are accused of sex trafficking
minors
the international twist after the break
[Music]
welcome back turken star joe exotic is
suing the department of justice
because he says his partner request was
rejected
attorneys for exotic claim the request
was never presented directly to the
president
according to the lawsuit the big cat
lover submitted his application on
september 8th
and received an email two days later
saying it was denied
exotic whose real name is maldonado
passage
is serving a 22-year sentence for
falsifying wildlife records
and violating the endangered species act
and in the george floyd case a judge
will hear arguments over
whether the trial date for the ex-cops
should be pushed back
the defense attorneys for the four
former officers want to delay the trial
scheduled for march of 2021. they say
they need more time to prepare
because prosecutors are taking too long
to turn over discovery
derek chovin is charged with
second-degree manslaughter the three
others are charged with aiding and
abetting
murder and manslaughter they are set to
stand trial together
a modeling agent accused of procuring
victims for jeffrey epstein
has been taken into custody authorities
announced the arrest of
jean-luc bernal for charges of rape
sexual assault
and human trafficking bernal is the
founder of a french modeling management
company
he was arrested in paris attempting to
board a flight
at least one of epstein's accusers said
burnell helped bring models
including underage girls to be sexually
abused epstein died in jail last year
but his former madame gilain maxwell is
awaiting trial
federal prosecutors in new york say they
fear she was going to flee to france
before her arrest in july
maxwell was among epstein's closest
associates
and helped him exploit girls who were
as young as 14 years old
maxwell played a critical role in
helping epstein to identify
befriend and groom minor victims for
abuse
in some cases maxwell participated in
the abuse
herself that abuse included
sexualized massages during which the
minor
victim was fully or partially nude
the sexualized massages developed into
sexual encounters
for which maxwell in some instances was
present
and participated maxwell and epstein
worked together
to entice these minor victims to travel
to epstein's residences
all right so terry as we see another
potential defendant in this case come up
do you see someone potentially flipping
on another person
to get a good plea deal you know that's
entirely
possible brian because you know you have
two defendants and
neither one of them wants to get
convicted and brunelle
is someone who the you know victims are
saying
used his position in the modeling world
and they were very happy they said they
had tears of joy when he was
actually caught so i do think he has a
lot to lose
i do think that he could very well flip
and blame
everything on you know uh jillaine
maxwell
of course because maxwell would be the
big fish here so you'd expect that
linda if you're maxwell's attorney how
are you feeling
about this bernal arrest well a couple
things you know that he was caught going
on a plane to senegal
that doesn't have an expedition treaty
with the united states but we're
assuming
that she hasn't already helped give
information that made his
accessibility to be apprehended
even easier shall we say remember she
just filed a renewed bail application
why would she do that just now unless
maybe
she has been cooperating so there's some
things we
do not know so do you think maybe and
i'll appeal this to you again linda
maybe something maxwell said could have
led to the arrest of burnell
sure it could have been information
she's already given we don't know
whether there's been any type of
discussions with her attorney whether
there's been asked for some good faith
shall we say evidence that could help
the government
we know nothing about that and we really
don't know who the government really
sees
as the big fish in this they have
maxwell in prison
right now we're pending uh you know
pending trial now they have brunel
pending trial
who else are they after we simply are
not on the inside of this case
i mean that's a great question there who
else are they after of course we're just
kind of reading tea leaves but terry do
you see
a longer list of arrests coming down the
pipeline
as more and more people get arrested
here i do i think it takes time the
victims have always said that there were
multiple people
involved in this sex ring and so i think
we're going to see
other people who are in high places
coming and
maybe being arrested and so i don't
think this is the end of it and
i think that the prosecution's going to
take as much
information as they can and they're
going to use as
many of these individuals as they can to
get information on those who might still
be out there so
i also wanted to just add i do think the
victims are helping a lot here to name
these individuals
yeah of course we always knew epstein
was a ringleader but we always said that
maxwell kind of has the receipts
linda terry thank you for joining us and
thank you for joining us here at law on
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you